all right so one of the things that
you've been talking about
is that you've been seeing more hijabs
uh in canada in general i think you were
talking about montreal specifically is
that right
now i see the way the hijab has been
fetishized here in america
for example the the fencer that just won
i think was it she should have been the
flag barrier
above a guy who holds the all-time
record
for most medals because she wears she
makes she has made a sartorial decision
right i clearly it was islamophobic not
today so for the people
who aren't quite following the sarcasm
there i i think you're referring to the
piece that was written on cnn you saw
that yes sir
saying that basically she should carry
the flag at the ceremonies
instead of michael phelps despite his 21
gold medals and blah blah blah she did
win one
thing and but it would be better for
society if we showed her
but so they fetishized it i have no
problem with her wearing it if it's her
choice of course i would be for anyone
doing what they want with their body
um but i would always take the most
successful athlete
in an olympic competition call me crazy
um
so what do you make of the situation in
montreal specifically
uh because i don't think you're against
you're not in and of itself against the
hijab right
so people actually write and say you
know are you just against people
choosing what to wear
i mean it's astonishing that you could
be so myopically stupid right
if i wear a shirt that says uh i
despise people with green eyes right
it's not just there's a message to that
t-shirt right
so the hijab is also a political
statement right it is basically saying
that there is increased islamization
that is
conspicuously around us right now
individual woman might
it might certainly be the case that she
chooses we don't have any empirical data
that i'm aware of that tells us
how many of these women are forced
versus how many choose it freely
but we know through again a history
that if you look at women in afghanistan
in 1950
if you look at women in iran in 1960s
and 70s if you look at women
in pakistan if you look at women all
over those regions in egypt
if you know graduating class in
cairo university from 1970 to today
it seems quite astonishing that they've
all decided at the same time
to freely don massive uh islamic garb
the more likely statistical
probabilistic argument
is that there is now an environment that
is forcing women to wear that right
so there is a message to that garb
right and therefore when i you know and
from 1975 to 2003
that's when we moved to montreal 1975 i
had seen
a single woman in islamic garb in my
entire life
in montreal from 2003 till today
you can walk in areas of montreal where
30
40 50 of the women are veiled sometimes
it's not just hijab
it's it's more you know islamic garb
right that doesn't
bode well in terms of secularism and
liberalism and modernity okay so that's
the part that i think is important here
so you're not
in and of itself you don't care that
this woman is wearing this
if she chose it and as you said there
isn't enough information
studies to prove whether she was forced
or not whatever but it's what
it what it's what it really says about
society as a whole
right because you can get a sense that
people that wear religious guard
probably are going to vote in certain
ways that will be against secular values
so that's why it's not racist or bigoted
if you are
just a free thinker to not want and it's
also always women why is it always women
right how many men are walking around
well i've taken several i've done very
little as you said
social media but in two instances i've
taken photos
of uh fully veiled women on southern
california beaches
the men that they're with are completely
dressed right
where are the feminists arguing about
that right so the guys are allowed to
naturally experience
the environment of the beach but the
women have to be cloaked
an incredibly restrictive thing doesn't
that seem
sexist yeah but then i'll get attacked
but so what if she wears
a bag over her whole body and there are
only slits that allow her to see the
laguna beach
who are what do you mean who am i i mean
again we have
common sense right i mean do most women
if they've given a choice
would they prefer to be dressed in a bag
over their head rather than wearing
shorts and experiencing the beauty of
the pacific ocean
come on right so the critic will make it
sound like you're
focusing on that but actually what
you're doing is you're using the same
principles
across the board you're not focusing on
that you're pointing something out
because
it's an aberration to the way the rest
of the society
behaves and by the way to prove that
we're not gross and racist
i mean you know i look i live here in
california it's probably 95 degrees out
right now
they're going to be orthodox jewish men
wearing big wool hats and crazy long
jackets i think that's equally as
bonkers yes they're not forcing other
people to do it which is a difference
uh that bill warner made a point uh when
you had him on your show
and i had him on and he brought that up
that there's a difference in the way the
religions act
so in that case those orthodox guys as
silly as that may be
they're not trying to spread that to
non-believers well let's let's let me
add another point let's
make it personal so i'm jewish right if
i
see the hasidic guy dressed in his garb
as a matter of fact
i do in the privacy of my car as i drive
by with my wife say
look at these guys do it all the time
i'm not feeling happy about it so now
you're an anti-semite
i hate jews yeah right but i know that
this guy
poses literally zero threat to me
now there are endless studies that we
have data
looking at jew hatred not not
israel hatred jew hatred stemming from
islamic countries 95 99
93 the numbers are not good so if i see
somebody who is
advertising their identity
and that identity has a probability
of 95 to 100 percent hating me
have i evolved the brain to be minimally
concerned
about having an increase of those people
just statistically speaking
notwithstanding that many women who wear
the hijab i could probably invite them
over to my house for dinner and vice
versa
and they could become my best friends
statistically on average in the same way
that when i walk into the dark alley
i am more afraid of four young men than
four elderly women
i'm more afraid of somebody who is
exhibiting their fundamentalist
religiosity
if it's islamic than if it's jewish yeah
and that's why i started this with the
olympic thing because
when the in the judo match when the
israeli put his hand out and the
egyptian wouldn't shake his hand first
off
these countries have a peace agreement
they've been at peace there has not been
one
israeli killed by an egyptian or
egyptian killed by an israeli since 1979
or probably
probably before that probably since the
1973 war or something
um and also egypt lets no aid into gaza
so
egypt you could very you could make a
very strong case that egypt is
they've sealed off the border they've
destroyed all the tunnels uh they shoot
people they try to get out of gaza that
they're much worse
to the gazans than israel is where all
the aid comes through
so it's a fake so the point is that no
choice no news
exactly no jews no there's not one jew
in guys but my point being that
this person he's we have two countries
that are at peace he wouldn't shake this
guy's hand not because
it's a cold piece it was because he's
the jew absolutely
look i've i think maybe sam harris
mentioned this
tweet that i had sent out i think the gl
gun about my t-shirt test
oh right right right yeah go ahead so
let me reiterate please right
uh to anybody who tries to argue about
no but it's peaceful and they're
right just i will pay right or maybe
because of all your massive patreon
donations
i will pay to the idiot who who utters
that stupidity
a ticket to go to the place that i
choose
but you have to tape it with a t-shirt
that says i'm a gay jew
i love judaism and walk around in that
neighborhood
come back to us and let us know how it
goes yeah
probably not that well you probably
don't come back to us so it's a one-way
ticket so
thank you i appreciate your altruism
i'll flip the bill um all right so let's
go a little more on this sort of
moralizing stuff um
we have been emailing privately uh i'm
gonna expose a little bit of our private
email
from from about a week ago uh you were
telling me a bit about how you were sort
of caught in a
in a emob
of sorts that people ask you a lot of
things they ask for favors they ask for
retweets on this or help this person or
that person
i get a lot of it too i do things
privately that i don't
talk about but sometimes there's
legitimate security reasons that i don't
talk about it sometimes it's just
i don't have to sit here and pat myself
in the back whatever it's fine that
even that sounded i didn't even like the
way that came out but um
but basically you were asked to sort of
help somebody right
go ahead good so as you said i mean
people don't
appreciate the number of messages that
we receive
in the hundreds and the thousands right
it's endless
yeah and i received them on my gmail
account on my university address on my
private facebook page on my public
facebook page on twitter
so i am bombarded endlessly by all sorts
of requests
the reality is being who i am i'm
astonishingly accessible way more
accessible everybody's told me please
reduce your
you're going to burn yourself out yeah
so i come on vacation here and i take
the position that
i'm not going to you know uh
work right anything that i'm going to
post is going to be related to my
vacation
here i am surfing here here i am
whatever
to prove this you called me to tell me
that you weren't going to respond
to my tweet that i said about that
because so you're not lying i know
you're not lying yeah
so then this gentleman wrote so
put some tweets out tagging me several
times i think
then he posted on my public facebook
page then sent me several
private messages the smart thing for me
would have been to just ignore
okay because of my purity sitting at the
beach with my children playing around
i wrote back hey buddy look i'm on
vacation you know layoff right i mean i
was a bit indignant
he writes back he's upset that you know
i was rude
and then i block and ban him so then the
e-mob is starting first they release our
private exchange
which is there's nothing to hide in that
private exchange but that's a huge
social faux pas right
so already that and then they start with
the emob you know this this guy is
taking pictures of him at the beach
but he can't retweet something he
doesn't but they don't appreciate
that i if i did first of all i have to
vet what that tweet is
that means i'd have to take half an hour
to an hour who's this guy what's the
thing that they're asking for right
what's the cause is it but i also have
300 other
such requests right why yours i've
received a request from
people who've come on your show famous
people i write i wrote back to them very
much like i wrote to this kid
although less indignant because they
weren't hounding me as much
and i said hey sorry x and y i'm on
vacation
what did they write back because they're
saying gentlemen oh i'm sorry i didn't
know you were on vacation no worries god
this kid posts you know [ __ ] this i
mean we
forget about who would speak like that
to somebody right i'm old enough to be
your dad right
right so so the reality is that there is
an ugliness
people don't appreciate what we do you
know 95 percent
i'm a professor who has a full-time job
as a very serious academic
i don't even need to be involved in this
public debate i take great personal
and professional risks to do what i do
so now i want a couple of weeks where
i'm not
bombarded by all this ugliness that
ugliness exists whether i'm at the beach
or not
i just want to break from it for a week
or two no i'm a pig who doesn't
appreciate the
danger that this guy's going through
well i bring it up not so that you can
prove what a good person you are which i
know is not what you're what you're
trying to do there
but to just show that there's a personal
piece of this that this online world
that we've all been part of and you have
a channel on youtube which i want to
talk about in a second
and putting stuff out there on twitter
and all this stuff that it's connected
us and at the same time it does
rip us apart in a weird way so so i'm i
suspect
that the person that sent you this
probably is a huge admirer of your work
knows that you care
about the same things that they care
about and yet because you didn't behave
in one instance how they wanted you now
you're the enemy
hitler right you're now you're hitler
and this but this is the danger of
what's happening online
and i think we're starting to see it
permeate into every part of society and
let's let's be very pragmatic now
just because of my personality when
these guys come at me
you know it's only going to embolden me
more i mean i just
because i am walking big testicles
our approach to this is very different
you you do the attack to me it's like
it's just the unique combination of
genes that make who godzad is
means that these kinds of guys are not i
mean i face threats from
much bigger guys than an 18 year old you
know who's a castrato who calls me [ __ ]
i face in terms of the hierarchy of
threats that i receive
he's not very threatening to me right
but let's suppose i decided
let's just let's just play out an
exercise yeah i decided you know what
i hate receiving all this hate stuff who
wants to be at you know when you're
doing this for only pure
pure reasons right i mean you're doing
this to introduce your small voice
to the greater debate i decide you know
what guys good night i'm packing it in
would that be a good thing so if i
decided that if tomorrow you decided
you know what i'm tired of the hate
right so these guys who are supposedly
on our side
by acting in this brutal barbaric emob
manner
it might not dissuade me but it could
but
it could dissuade this person now if we
bring it to another context
what about the 12 year old girl who is
receptive to a similar emob who doesn't
have
the structure of personhood that gazad
has
i could look at it it annoys me for an
hour i'm upset but then i forget about
it i don't care yeah i move on
but that 12 year old doesn't have the
same thing but it's the same phenomenon
right
there's an anonymity here we emob and we
trash
and that's truly grotesque and i wish
people would think about it before they
do it yeah i guess it's that we don't
take a breath sometimes before we
realize what we're doing you know
as you're saying that i'm i'm recalling
during the last attack in brussels
um i saw just within within as it was
unfolding i mean they didn't even know
how many people were dead
i saw someone that i didn't know it was
just a random person tweets something
about
even worse than the than the dead is
that is the amount of islamophobia this
is going to create
right and i retweeted and i said this is
the very definition
of regressive left that we're more
concerned about an
idea that may cause some
ill will towards and towards an idea
right
i'm not talking about hurting people
that we're more concerned about that
than actual dead bodies that are still
warm and being counted
and it happened to be a random person
and i got a couple thousand reviews and
i actually felt bad after
because i felt that i had then uh
unleashed
you know the the mob on some random
person
so it's it works every which way and
none of us are perfect i think is the
point of this that you try to do good
but sometimes and how about just being
decent right i mean a lot of people
incidentally
out of the endless number of people who
kind of
weighed in on this you know 99 said were
like
hey the guy is on a break with his
family right off you don't think he does
enough
but you know one percent of a very large
number yeah
is still a big num a big tsunami of hate
and so again stop and think before you
do this
do you want the people that you
supposedly admire that you respect
to ultimately be driven out because of
your hatred or do you want to
encourage us to continue so we you know
you and i already receive
tons of hate from really nefarious folks
we don't need additional hate from
supposedly our friends
yeah now i suspect despite the hate or
the memes that people may send you and
you know i've mentioned this a few times
before but ben shapiro who's orthodox
jew where's where's yamaka so he's
putting himself out there
uh in a certain respect you know i've
seen the horrible memes that people
show him in auschwitz and in ovens and
terrible stuff and all this stuff
my policy on all this is i either i
basically i ignore it i don't engage
with these people if a
crazy random person came up to me on the
street that i didn't know and started
screaming at me
i would ignore them so why would i not
ignore the crazy online person
um so you would be you were not you're
not for banning these people or any of
that stuff right you're fully for
banning them from my page or banning
them from speaking
well well i meant from speaking but
you're okay you should speak as much as
you want look as i've always said
uh you know i support holocaust deniers
yeah i mean i mean it's difficult to to
give an example of somebody who supports
free speech more than
a jewish person saying that i support
a guy who denies the reality
that is about as clear a historical fact
as the existence of gravity
right so i support the right of these
people to be
[ __ ] here's the difference though i
sometimes will ban
and block people because they're just
they're just endlessly
you know abusive right then they will
find
a way to start a narrative that how
could i be for free speech right right
because free speech is about allowing an
intruder into your
shower and when you go in he starts
saying
hey fat boy take a shower fat boy fat
boy
and if i kick him out of my house i am
forbidding his free speech i mean
you must be so incorrect in your
thinking about what free speech is
actually make that argument and hence
that's why you're naturally lobotomized
right so to be absolutely clear
you're not against them exercising their
free speech you just don't have to be
the
knowing recipient of it nor give them a
platform so for example on your facebook
page if someone was slamming it all day
with and fighting with people and all
that you don't have to give them that
spot to do it they can do it wherever
they want
but somehow now you're the enemy of free
speech or they then say
oh the guy speaks against safe space but
he wants a safe space again
they completely misunderstand what safe
space is a
term that developed in the context of
universities
where you're supposed to by definition
be exposed to a multiplicity of ideas
that's what education is and then a
bunch of people are saying no but if you
hold an
idea that's different from mine that
makes me feel unsafe
here i'm saying look i'm tired of
hearing you
call me fat and therefore i'd like to
shut off your voice
that's not creating a safe space in the
way that we criticize safe spaces on
universities
so they're just so you know
pathologically confused
yeah it's funny because on my own
facebook page i think i've banned
maybe three people and i can't even
swear that it's that many but it was for
just that if you were just in there to
fight
i didn't care what you were saying about
me but if you're just in there to fight
everybody else
with with just epitaphs and racial stuff
and language
it's like i just that's not the forum
that i've that i want to create in this
world it's not what i do
here physically with you right now and
it's not the forum that i want to create
on the well
and look at i mean look at the
interactions that we we both have with
our guests on our shows
they're always respectful they're always
pleasant people always want to come back
on our shows and so on precisely because
we create
you can't have a conversation if you're
calling the other person
[ __ ] and fat and gay and i mean that's
not
how reasonable rational people engage in
serious conversations you know how hard
it is for me to sit here and not be
using all those terms
all the time and i treat everybody i see
incredible tan that's what i see just
incredible